>> WE WILL BE GETTING BACK TO
FLORIDA AND THE DESTRUCTION IN
A MOMENT.
FIRST THOUGH, SOURCES TELLING
US ON CNN THAT EUROPEAN
SECURITY OFFICIALS OBSERVED
RUSSIAN NAVY SHIPS EARLIER THIS
WEEK IN THE VICINITY OF THOSE
LEAKS IN THE NORD STREAM
PIPELINES THAT WERE LIKELY
CAUSED BY UNDERWATER
EXPLOSIONS.
WITH MORE ON THIS WE HAVE CNN
REPORTER KATIE BOWLUS, SHE'S
PART OF THE TEAM THAT BROKE THE
STORY.
KATIE, DO THESE SHIPS HAVE
ANYTHING TO DO WITH THESE
EXPLOSIONS THAT WERE REVEALED,
BELIEVED TO BE RESPONSIBLE, FOR
LEAKS IN THESE PIPELINES?
>> IT'S A GOOD QUESTION,
BREONNA.
THEY DON'T KNOW THE ANSWER TO
THIS.
AT THIS POINT, IT'S ONE OF MANY
FACTORS THAT INVESTIGATORS WILL
BE LOOKING AT TO TRY AND GET A
SENSE OF WHAT ACTUALLY HAPPENED
HERE.
HERE'S WHAT WE KNOW.
WE KNOW THE RUSSIAN SUPPORT
SHIPS, THE RUSSIAN NAVY SUPPORT
SHIPS, OR SPOTTED IN THE
VICINITY OF THE LEAKS IN THESE
PIPELINES.
WE WERE ALSO TOLD BY A SOURCE
FAMILIAR WITH THE INTELLIGENCE
THAT RUSSIAN SUBMARINES WERE
SPOTTED IN THE GENERAL AREA
LAST WEEK.
BUT IT'S IMPORTANT TO NOT JUMP
TO TOO MANY CONCLUSIONS HERE AS
ONE DANISH MILITARY OFFICIAL
PUT IT TO ME WHO SAID, WE SEE
RUSSIAN SHIPS OPERATING IN
THESE PARTS OF THE BALTIC SEA
PRETTY ROUTINELY.
THEY ARE TESTING OUR AWARENESS.
THE PRESENCE OF THE SHIPS DOES
NOT NECESSARILY INDICATE THEY
HAD ANYTHING TO DO WITH THE
EXPLOSIONS, BUT AT THIS POINT
WE BELIEVE PAUSED AT THE
STAKES.
>> LOOK, WE DON'T KNOW WHO DID
IT.
THERE'S A QUESTION OF WHO HAS
THE MOTIVE AND THE CAPABILITY.
A LOT OF EXPERTS SAY RUSSIA.
THAT IS WHY THEY ARE LOOKING AT
THAT EVEN THOUGH THEY CANNOT
PROVE IT AT THIS POINT IN TIME.
SO WHAT HAPPENS NEXT?
>> SO DENMARK AND SWEDEN ARE
BOTH INVESTIGATING.
THAT'S ANOTHER REALLY GOOD
QUESTION.
DENMARK AND SWEDEN ARE BOTH
INVESTIGATING.
THE U.S. SAID THEY WILL PROVIDE
THEM WITH INTELLIGENCE THAT IT
HAS IN THEIR POSSESSION, BUT WE
SPOKE TO MULTIPLE U.S.
OFFICIALS YESTERDAY WHO SAID
THE UNITED STATES JUST STILL
DOESN'T REALLY HAVE A FIRM
SENSE OF WHAT HAPPENED HERE.
THEY ARE BEING A LITTLE MORE
CIRCUMSPECT THAN SOME EUROPEAN
OFFICIALS HAVE BEEN PUBLICLY
SAYING THAT WE BELIEVE THIS WAS
SABOTAGE, IT'S OUR ASSESSMENT
THIS WAS SABOTAGE.
PART OF THE PROBLEM HERE IS
THAT THE EUROPEANS HAVE NOT
BEEN ABLE TO GET A SITE
INSPECTION DONE YET.
THEY HAVE NOT BEEN ABLE TO GET
A DIVER DOWN TO THE PHYSICAL
LOCATION OF THE LEAGUES TO TAKE
A LOOK AT WHAT ACTUALLY
HAPPENED.
IT'S OUR UNDERSTANDING THAT
THERE'S SOME LOGISTICAL, AND I
WOULD PRESUME ALSO SAFETY
CONCERNS, WITH ACTUALLY GETTING
A DIVER DOWN THERE.
AT THIS POINT WE ARE HEARING
FROM BOTH U.S. AND EUROPEAN
OFFICIALS THAT THEY BELIEVE
RUSSIA IS THE PRIMARY SUSPECT
HERE, LARGELY FOR THE REASON
THAT YOU SAID, BECAUSE THESE
OFFICIALS SAY WHAT OTHER ACTOR
IS THERE THAT HAS BO